schröder darf ich sie kurz stören vom
zdf es geht um folgendes herr lafontaine
ja alter freund es auch heute da wir
wollen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
schön dass sie da sind lafontaine ja und
dass ich diesen mut haben hier heute
dabei zu sein wunderbar und damit
herzlich willkommen in unserer kleinen
aber feinen sendung verzeih mir aus kann
red zusammen zu kriegen glauben sie ist
dass ich meine jetzt aus dem film zu
kreieren ja natürlich die beiden mal
wieder zusammen zu kriegen also dass ich
mal wieder miteinander reden und warum
warum weil ich schon ganz andere leute
dazu gebracht habe sich zu versöhnen
obama und osama modern und talking und
sogar philipp rösler und die fdp ist da
noch was also brezelt da noch manchmal
oder ist dass er so wir haben ja das ist
ja bekannt lieferant sie aber das liegt
lange zurück glauben sie ist es immer
noch so ein bisschen so was sich liebt
das neckt sich soll sich das jetzt
bestätigt haben sie dann was zu lachen
gleich werden der gerhard und der oscar
nach zehn jahren wieder aufeinander
treffen und wird es dann heißen bitte
verzeihen aber warum dürfen alle hier
renovieren nicht wie ich komme vom
verzeiht mir ich bitte sie jetzt auch
wieder gehen setzt man soll ja
[Musik]
so
schröder darf ich sie kurz stören vom
zdf
es geht um folgendes herr lafontaine ja
alter freut es auch heute da wir wollen
präsidenten zizi bereits die hand zu
reichen
herr putin einen plan für unsere sendung
bitte herr schröder bitte wir haben
natürlich die möglichkeit noch mit
[Musik]
also das muss ich ganz entschieden
zurück wie sie sind sturer bock
so ist das halt mit spuren keine chance
[Musik]